Remember that you can get 70 percent off The
David Pakman Show membership using the coupon
code fresh start.
Why?
Because we're taking a fresh start here.
It's a new beginning.
Use that coupon code fresh start all one word,
all lowercase to discount the membership of
your choice at joined Pakman Dotcom.
I have something completely shocking to report
to you.
President elect Joe Biden has announced his
coronavirus task force.
There's not a single member of his family
on it.
None of Joe Biden's family is on the task
force.
Not a single pillow salesman is on the task
There's no faith healers on the task force.
It's just doctors.
The task force includes seven doctors.
David Kessler, a pediatrician, former surgeon
general, Dr. Marcella Nunez Smith, who's a
professor of epidemiology at Yale, Dr Rick
Bright, and immunologist and vaccine researcher
who refused to do Trump's propaganda bidding.
Dr. Zeke Emanuel, who's a bioethicist.
Dr. Atul Gawande, a surgeon and public health
expert.
Dr. Michael Osterholm, another epidemiologist
actually having Atul Gawande story.
Atul Gawande wrote this great book, The Checklist
Manifesto.
And when I had my appendectomy 2:00 a.m. in
the morning, this was like a year ago.
Surgeon comes in, Dr. Matthew Nay's says,
hey, here's who I am.
Here's the office I work in.
And his specialty was I think it was like
endocrinology surgery.
It just sounded a lot like what I know Dr.
Atul Gawande is specialty is I'm all zoned
out in the middle, you know, I'm on drugs,
appendectomy, all this stuff.
And I say, Do you know Atul Gawande?
And he says, I do.
It's my officemate or whatever.
And at that point, I at least hoped I was
in good hands.
I was very drugged up.
It was easy to convince me that I was and
it worked out great.
But anyway, Dr. Atul Gawande, a really good
guy, great inclusion, but a group of just
doctors with relevant specializations and
a picture of their first meeting was released.
Joe Biden.
Yes, Joe Biden already has held his first
coronavirus task force meeting.
He's still months out from being president.
Joe Biden just sat there taking notes.
You see, if you're looking at the picture
of the meeting, there was no TV on in the
back of the room.
So if Joe Biden got bored, he could watch
Fox News or something.
So obviously, I'm being sort of jokey, but
this is very serious.
This is a real change in the trajectory of
the U.S. dealing with coronavirus in that
the president will deal with it and will deal
with it with relevant doctors.
No media figures, no radiologists saying let's
go for herd immunity, no TV anchors, no nonsense.
And the one little flavor I like is that the
inclusion of Rick Bright in this group of
doctors is very likely to heavily trigger
Donald Trump.
You might remember Dr Rick Bright was a Trump
whistleblower who came out and said they're
pushing me to start saying things about hydroxy
chloroquine that are not based, in fact.
And of course, Rick Bright was correct.
Nobody talks about hydroxy chloroquine anymore.
He was one of the few people doing good work
at the time and he blew the whistle.
And his inclusion here is very likely to trigger
Donald Trump.
Now, there was a question, why no foushee?
Where is Dr. Fauci?
Why is Dr. Fauci not part of this?
My assumption is that Joe Biden understands
Dr. Fauci is running NIH.
He is, you know, loosely speaking, an administration
employee.
And it would not really be appropriate to
include him in this group right now.
I'm sure that if Donald Trump fires Dr. Fauci
or when Dr. when when Joe Biden is inaugurated,
Dr. Fauci is going to be a part of this.
There is no question whatsoever.
I don't think Fauci is sitting there.
You know, rigging is wringing his hands, wondering
if he will be useful to the incoming administration.
I'm sure he knows that he will be.
And I think Joe Biden is probably probably
doing the appropriate thing by not yet including
him.
But we're already off to you know, this is
going to be a long fight and we're going to
need to wear masks for for some time.
And things are not going to be normal for
some time.
But this is a start that certainly inspires
some confidence.